so we thought maybe it'll be interesting
to start off at this part of the panel
with a bit of a splash thank yous and
gentlemen you're Aquaman
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Brooklyn
[Applause]
the keys here
[Applause]
finally it makes sense to your uncle can
make sense in your aqua because everyone
is super wet right now
[Applause]
this man I want you to know this man
came all the way from Australia last
night to be I came all the way from
Australia for you guys I'm gonna be tea
man
congratulations have been welcome to all
this I mean what is it what can you say
about art the Korean what have you
enjoyed and what's been exciting your
buddy oh I'm not worthy for this I feel
it's been awesome yeah I had a great
time in London Justice League I love
them no I wasn't stop making all my
training yeah it's just so stoked to
show you what we have today eight 18
months away from Aquaman and there's a
lot of stuff we do want to show you
unfortunately I wish I could take this
and go and you guys can see what I've
seen but unfortunately we can't show too
much can't show too much yeah we're a
little ways away but we made something
really really special yeah you've been
working with James Wan absolutely he's a
little genius man I love him yeah we're
having a great time down there he wish
he could be here everyone does amber
Patrick everyone says hello yeah love my
cast and we made a little special day
yeah James made a special message for
you let's say
gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
whoop Wow you guys there are energies
we're revealing you Wow Jason that was
freakin credible I cannot wait how are
you guys doing today I mean I know you
know I know it goes thing but it really
means a lot to everyone here that you
that you all showed up to unite for this
here at comic-con but but obviously it's
I know it's a lot of hard work Ben what
did it feel like when you finally United
as the Justice League this is an amazing
cast the first time when everyone had
their costumes on and we were on the set
and it was everybody it was it was very
much a high geek level moment it was
just electrifying is incredible I just
kept trying to touch everyone it looks
so cool and real it is real then there's
been some stories in the past day or so
and they just kind of want to know you
know let me be very clear I am the
luckiest guy in the world
Batman is the coolest [ __ ] part in
any universe DC Marvel it's incredible
and you know I I'm so thrilled to do it
I know there's misconception because I
didn't directed that maybe I wasn't
enthusiastic about it it's [ __ ]
amazing and and I still can't believe it
after two films and we'll have this
history with this great studio and you
know Kevin tsujihara and sue Crowell and
Toby I'm Ric has said to me we want you
to be our Batman and you know I believe
him and with Matt Reeves doing it it's
like I would be a [ __ ] ape on the
ground for Matt Reeves never mind being
Batman it's incredible so I'm really
blown away and excited and and it's a
great time in the DC Universe you're
gonna see some stuff from Justice League
that we're really really proud of and I
think you'll see why I'm so excited to
be Batman excellent thank you believing
the hype people don't believe the hype
gal I remember we were on this stage a
few years ago and what has happened with
one woman is an incredible it's a
beautiful movie you are so wonderful in
it and so what what is it specifically
about Wonder Woman that's special to you
and what why do you think that it has
resonated so globally the way that the
way that it has I think that No thank
you so are you whoever you are I think
that you know this character is just so
incredible she stands for everything
that is good for love and for compassion
and for truth and justice and peace and
and there's nothing not to love about
her and yeah and honestly I'm grateful
that you guys have made her who she is
and made this movie so so so successful
and you know I can only celebrate this
character and be super grateful for the
opportunity there legitimately like
three or four times a day since I saw
the movie that I that I just out loud go
beer near near near near near near near
near near near like when I'm trying to
run on a treadmill or something
esra as a self-proclaimed fanboy and I
think that it tracks so Ezra what what
is it about this universe that you love
so much and being being such an integral
part of it well well well thought you'd
never ask
well as we know the DC Universe is the
first comic universe that we are in is
the first unless you count the the only
one who came before us was the Justice
Society of America which is of course us
as well
yeah and so I I mean I'm thrilled what
more can I say it's the greatest as far
as I'm coming
I there's a couple startups that I'm
Claire yeah those but no I mean pretty
much you know the monopoly it's unfair I
know there's Marmaduke I don't know if
there's anything else
yeah what about what about Ray cuz
because these characters essentially get
their powers as a result of an accident
so how does that unite them how does
that bond them well with cyborg and the
flash you know they do get their powers
as a result of accidents and I think
that Bond's them in a very specific way
both through the traumas that they've
had but also due to the fact that
they're the youngest members of the
group you know you're getting well I
didn't say the most beautiful but you're
so well paid what I think works is that
you know you have all these characters
that are dealing with their personal
issues who come together for lack of a
better term come together and and are
able to use those circumstances to save
the world which is beautiful I mean
everybody here has gone through some
sort of family or emotional situation
and you know you find you find solace
and people that are like you and so they
see each other in how they interact you
know they see each other in their
purpose and you know it's gonna be a
hell of a good time excellent this is
for Jason Aquaman seems a little less
willing to play with the group what's
what's going on let's talk about it
hello oh and now you're on big trouble
yeah I just think he's you know
Aquaman's always he's not really
accepted on land or in sea so he kind of
lives in the tides he's just very I
guess he's hurt he's sensitive and he
covers it up there's a lot of there's a
lot of you know he's a big onion and
we're just slowly peeling it away yeah
but inside don't you
see the bees a little teddy bear right
over the bat-cave it says this is a safe
space you don't you don't feel that when
we're together I do I do
alright this is a personal conversation
but it's you know he comes through and
he ends up joining the league and it's
the greatest thing that's ever happened
to him you know and he's loved and
wanted and feels a part of the team
well you I think it might be time for to
serve up some justice so Ben what did
what you bring today for yeah I gotta
say I just want to take one second to
two to just absorb this because it's
really really great
it's so exciting how many people in
their life get to come to Hall H and say
I'm Batman I mean it's pretty it's
pretty amazing I'm Batman
it was fun I wanna say - up there - we
have something pretty I think it's
pretty great and you'll see all these
guys and how amazing they are and I
didn't I don't think it doesn't need
much introduction let's let's show
okay what are we doing what's happening
I don't think I'm a part of this
[Music]
I thought I was going to be a projectile
in like two seconds good leg catch me go
do mania yeah Wrestlemania now let there
be fine it's a great way that mean the
footage was fantastic footage of you
guys look amazing the footage looks
amazing we absolutely should open up the
floor to some questions because I know
people will have some now it's not so
fun to pick up the chairs when you throw
them
thank you okay
[Applause]
as a practice
we got another chair chittering Jared
this is the true Justice League over
here when Aquaman breaks a chair they
bring another one that's no it works
let's take some questions from the
audience
oh I see Dianna has a question what is
your probably for booze right it's been
hi my name is sherry congratulations
Gallagher really miss you have WonderCon
thank you Wonder Woman was an awesome
the question I have for the whole cast
when you first found out that you got
the role as what were you doing at that
moment actually what were you doing at
the moment when you found out you got
the role plane just landed and then I
got the calling then I started screaming
in the middle of the airplane they
finally found one woman don't freak out
don't freak out uh Jason I was in mr.
Schneider's office and he's going I want
you to play someone for me I'm like he
goes Aquaman and I'm like pardon me
[Laughter]
that was the biggest shock one of the
biggest shocks in my life
that's what do you have a small town in
Costa Rica Goro Tomita and was eating
some sort of delicious fish and I
received a call and it was my agent and
he was very panicked and he said I've
sent her on the phone you might start
going online and I said hold on
this fish is quite delicious give me
another one and then I said okay when I
pluck the bone from between my teeth and
I said I'm ready and Zack Snyder came on
the phone listen I have this idea it's
crazy idea yes I'm from the South I had
a full one of a fully realised
connection right there and people and
the Costa Rican people were alarmed this
man's crazy screaming and spitting fish
bones everywhere meanwhile that was
valid for them to think that hey what
about you where was I I was in my
apartment and I got a call I'm reading
another script cuz I'm thinking man I
probably found that Justice League
audition in the memory of the role and I
get a random call from Zacks assistant
saying thanks but you know we're going
in a different direction he gets on the
phone he's like so looks like we'll be
making a movie and I go I said a bunch
of words I can't say cuz it's a PG
audience right now and I started rolling
literally started rolling around on the
floor but I think he called me just to
hear that reaction is usually usually
you know you send it through the agent
or the manager and they're the ones that
break the news but he wanted to be the
one to tell personally and you know it's
just a testament to the kind of guy that
he is so you know he's with us even
though he's not with us
[Applause]
then do you have a yeah I the same thing
I was beating with Zach and he actually
I just see all the concept art and all
the stuff and basically he was like you
know I want to pitch this idea but
basically if you want to know what we're
doing we're doing this he took out the
this like sculpture from The Dark Knight
for the Frank Miller book of Batman and
Superman fighting I was like the extent
of his pitch fantastic uh yes what is
your question
Clark hi I first like to say I'm super
excited to be here this is my first
comic-con welcome my name is Raphael and
I want to say Holly H we all made it my
question is also for the entire cast but
before I say that I noticed Henry Cavill
is not up there so if you need a
Superman but I just want to know who's
you guys look like they have great team
chemistry who's the funniest and is
there like a funny prank story or
something that you guys can tell us I'm
gonna talk about prank stories I know
we're allowed to tell those ones I think
we're all funny in our own ways I think
that's what makes it so cool is that we
all have different sensibilities with
humor who I think we got lucky it's a
great group everybody's really really
cool and great to get oh my pleasure to
go to work every day and I was really
pretty special if you know that the
pranks are gonna have to become stories
later you got to reel them in big
you know I'm saying so yeah made up a
flat-out agreement at the jump
no no prank sharing these pranks stay
between us I mean is it is it it's when
you're coming in and there's a sort of
an established group already and you're
the new guy how are you how are you
seeing how to complement what's going on
and how are you seeing about fitting in
why am I the new guy okay
no I know I'm just saying like it's it's
it can be hard sure but you know
hopefully you just love yourself okay oh
that's really sweet what a nice offer
but learn to appreciate or tolerate you
[Laughter]
seriously why am i the new guy I don't
understand I don't mean the Justice
League like in the group well we're
we're all kind of the new guys and
Jaison myself thank you some research
man how dare you dare you this is my
house this is their house
[Applause]
well played well played well played what
is your name sir welcome to our house
hey what's up what the reshoots are you
guys secretly filming part two already
thank you
well if it's a secret we can't tell you
that first off right no I think we're
just about finished with everything
they've been briefed if anything but
yeah I mean josh is a great guy and Zack
picked a good person to come in and and
clean up and finish up for him so I got
some more time what's your name a
question hello first of all want to say
you're my boys but you're my gal but I
just want to know from each of you guys
if you could go toe to toe with the
Suicide Squad who would you like to
share a scene with from that cast Jai
Courtney boomerang I would do Margar Obi
no Will Smith and I have been planning
to have a fight for a long time and the
fresh prints are gonna go at it no holds
barred it's gonna be bloodbath honesty
I'd probably go Crocker enchantress
maybe you know maybe some science versus
magic on the Enchantress side of things
see how it all works out excellent thank
you so much hey man what's your question
my question is for the whole cast my
question is where is super movie you are
very very and it's a fair question yeah
it's a really really good question son
I'm not sure if your parents showed you
the last movie but Superman's dead oh
wow that is the
Wow you know hey guys that's just a fax
my kids are here too but they know he's
not around you know Aquaman just likes
to drop truth he just likes to talk
truth sometimes you'll see the movie I
drop all kinds of truth the soothsayer
we don't know I mean you guys probably
know but you probably can't say I don't
I don't know much but you're gonna be if
you're a big fan of Superman that I'm
sure you're gonna be very very happy to
watch Isis see that that's how you take
the one you want son thank you so much
hey what's your name what was the most
memorable scene in your movies that's a
really good question - how old are you
Wow who wants to go first I really liked
when we were all together as friends no
honestly we had so many great movies
that - but we have so many great moments
shooting that move with this movie but
for me the the most surreal moment was
when we were all in our costumes and we
were shooting a fight sequence and it
was just
unbeknown
or just continue staring at the monitor
watching the playbacks because it was so
crazy to see all of us in these
characters but that was the most
memorable moment that I had that day
anybody else when I got to see all the
bat gadgets we got to see the Batmobile
all the bat tech stuff that was super
memorable that wasn't necessarily the
shooting side of things but just is like
the fanboy in me
it was really pleased that day and also
I think there's a moment in the trailer
that we saw in the last one briefly
where it's going across the heroes and
there's an orange background that's the
the first time we're all together
standing together and like it it it was
beautiful
it was really really a special moment I
think my fangirl moment was probably on
the Batmobile surfing it with uh with my
boy ba down there surf from the
Batmobile my kids are watching me I'm
like daddy's got go to work then yeah I
mean mines the same when everybody was
was together and and you know also
there's there's really something
satisfying about getting to see it like
I finally get to see what ray looks like
in the movie he bores pajamas the whole
time we were shooting I did have a lot
of pajamas on I was the only one without
an actual costume but it worked cause
you know cyborg he feels a little
self-conscious about the way he looks so
that helped it helped a lot you have
nothing to be self-conscious thanks so
much we have one more question and I'm
so glad it's you Mike what is your what
is your question my question is for
Jason now I know you're a one-man army
but that battalion of ships that were in
the water in the water was that yours or
mantises or you can't tell you know what
I'm used to getting in trouble so you
know what I'm gonna tell you cuz they
sent me all the way to Austin from
Australia
so that's ocean masters army
blackmont ain't got nothing like that
that's that's that's my brother I'm
fighting my brother thank you Mike
so what loves you we are the next five
questions are for Jason to give us all
the secrets now how does it end what's
the last shot I just want to make sure
let you guys know that Justice League
opens November 17th three years ago on
this stage I took a picture with with
gaalan Ben and and Henry a little selfie
that I took and but now I I feel like
since since everyone's here
would you please indulge me because this
is an opportunity I don't know if that's
gonna happen again can we just take a
quick one one more time please
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Jason
[Applause]
you
you